I don't want to get too personal but I
also want to know everything about you
ohania uh you have this boyfriend do you
guys live together we do not we do not
and I have a huge house I'm just a loner
wait you have a big house I have a big
house uh that's why it might sound a
little echoey here I'm sorry I don't
have many furnitures in the office uh
but yeah it's a five bedroom house wow
wait a minute you are a single you're
single woman you have a boyfriend but he
doesn't live with you and you live in a
five-bedroom house I do I do he does
have his own room my boyfriend does have
his own room wait a minute you said you
don't I do have a heart away but he
doesn't live with you he doesn't live
with he does not but he has a room that
he's assigned to go to when he comes and
visits so he doesn't stay in your room
with you when he comes no because I have
two dogs and they're so big and I sleep
with my dogs wait a minute I'm a Loner
he likes me he likes me wait a minute no
I listen I'm not trying to be critical
I'm trying to help you but your
boyfriend comes over and this is a your
young people he's coming over to see you
but because you have dogs in a big house
you make him sleep in a separate room
that doesn't sound very romantic and you
you are living in
I'm a catch I mean he knows that that's
the price to pay to be with me I mean
I'm a pretty cool but he's also not with
you
yeah and when he's with me he brings me
Conan portraits because he knows where
my priorities lie nothing more erotic
than that hey
um oh hania I'm curious are you gonna
fix up your house is your is your house
going to be all fixed up I redid the
kitchen and one of the bathrooms because
this is like a three-story house and the
the the bottom floor is not mine I have
like the two top floors uh so the
bathroom I had was like had problems
with the plumbing and stuff so we had to
like take it all down and build it again
and I moved here but then I didn't
decorate I didn't bring a lot of
Furnitures because you have to fill like
a five bedroom house you have to fill it
and I don't have enough enough Furniture
right so
I mean that's why it sounds so echoey do
you have a room that's right I could I
mean if Conan wants to come here
uh
his room definitely tell me ohanya let's
say I did come visit you
um what would we do it's a city it's
pretty busy but then we're like 20
minutes away from like uh mountains and
rivers and lakes so it's pretty nice uh
either a summer and winter I've seen
mountains and lakes and stuff this might
be interesting right across the street
from my house I can see it right now
there's an Armenian restaurant so Sona
if you come okay that's terrific can I
go yeah no well listen we'll see Sona
well I'd like you to pay for me to go to
Cordova I'll take care of it in an
increasingly competitive job market it's
important to make sure your brand stands
out from the crowd that is important
Sona yeah that's right vegan cupcakes
from your kitchen or marketing your
wedding photography business I'm just
making these up yeah I can tell
Squarespace helps you create a modern
platform through engaging and
aesthetically pleasing online presence
that's important if things look nice
people will buy with member areas hmm
you can unlock a new Revenue stream for
your business and free up time in your
schedule by selling access to dated
content like videos online courses or
newsletters newsletters yeah stand out
in any inbox with email from Squarespace
email campaigns collect email
subscribers and convert them into loyal
customers social display posts from your
social profiles on your website
analytics you want to hear more I'll
give you some use insights to grow your
business learn where your site visits
and sales are coming from and analyze
which channels are most effective good
heavens and alert above head to
squarespace.com in for a free trial when
you're ready to launch use offer code
Conan to save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain
um what I'm more interested in and you
mentioned uh beautiful lakes and rivers
and streams but I want to hit the clubs
I mean you're talking about a very young
City and uh I would like to hit the
clubs and maybe you and your boyfriend
would come along tell me about about
your boyfriend what's he like he is
awesome he's 10 years younger than me I
am 37 so it's not like a dangerous
situation he's 27. wow what do you mean
it's not a dangerous situation do do
women start killing their mate when
they're when they hit 40 is that what
happened yes I meant illegal uh because
it might seem very young but um you're
37. 37 is Young I believe so there you
go I'm working so hard to play cool
um you are you're playing it very cool
uh well this is I'm I mean I'm learning
so much about you I like you a lot you
seem like a really nice person and
um Okay I accept you've got this guy in
your life uh and and he what's his name
again Martin Martin Martin I'm gonna
call him Martin
I must go to Cordoba and I must face
Martin uh
I just want to know about what we would
do together and and I like I say I don't
I want to go out and hit the The
Nightlife it must be a very vibrant
nightlife yes so I mean we could hit the
clubs so over the summer is really cool
because the clubs open in the
Mountainside oh so you're dancing up
until 6 a.m with like the mountain as
one of the walls of the club right
that's so cool so that's available I
don't really do it but I would do it for
you I mean I'm your ride or die while
we're here
um but I don't do I didn't even do it
when I was like 18 man but like I will I
didn't do anything when I was 18. take
one for the team I didn't leave my room
till I was 27. so this all I was packed
in uh heavy cream and refrigerated